it's time for our seen an unseen segment
where we reveal the stories behind the
headlines for that we turn to fox news
contributor raymond arroyo raymond um
hillary
is not back with a new streaming special
that cannot be happening she is laura as
someone once asked what difference does
it make well i'm going to tell you
hillary and her daughter chelsea are
launching this apple plus special called
gutsy i think anyone who sits through
this monstrosity is gutsy
we're hitting the road to shine a light
on women who inspire us to be bolder and
braver you said the gutsiest thing you
ever did was stay in your marriage that
doesn't mean that's right for everybody
you're not gonna break me down you'll
get worn out before i do
now laura first off who made hillary
clinton the curator of bold and
inspiring women and now i'm going to let
you answer the question you wrote the
book the hillary trap why do you think
she stayed in her marriage
um
u.s senate seat
presidential ambitions um let me count
the ways
a couple ideas couple of ideas now of
all the inspirational women for our
daughters to look up to you'd think
hillary would avoid a woman who brought
us [ __ ] megan the stallion and another
who made her name from a sex tape
under what circumstances may one use
deadly force to defend themselves yes
when one is being faced with deadly
force themselves or one believes that
deadly force is imminent
i was also really intrigued by how well
she did i wanted to
you know put the spotlight on her not
that she needs it
the spotlight on her hillary is clearly
putting the spotlight on herself laura
that's the whole reason for this thing
the fact that she lost a legal quiz to
kim kardashian is rather embarrassing
chelsea said it was because her mother
had a bad buzzer hand i think she's got
a bad beezer but we'll leave that aside
well i think kim kardashian is pretty
smart raymond i mean she's built a
massive empire maybe an interesting
beginning for sure but she's pretty uh
well i think she's really smart well she
and an entrepreneur nobody can take that
away from her and if you need a reminder
why hillary is straining to stay on the
public radar this is why laura the
president tonight took the stage at a
rally in maryland to whip up his base it
was an angry loud cranky speech devoted
to touting his spending bills
it's a big deal
some might even say it's a bfd
we also had to take on the climate
deniers
and guess what
we beat them
we beat them the maga republicans don't
just threaten our personal rights and
economic security
they're a threat to our very democracy
they refuse to accept the will of the
people
they embrace embrace political violence
they don't believe it
laura why does he talk like this all the
time it's always like this raymond
my bills are great but but it's a real
it's a real turnabout to try to suggest
that it's republicans who are embracing
violence laura after we saw the summer
of rage
monuments being toppled cities burned
supreme court justices targeted pro-life
clinics and churches defile who's
embracing violence come on yeah yeah
well that's all justifiable against the
racist you know outrageous domestic
terrorist class all right raymond i hear
that your mayor
down in new orleans
latoya cantrell is up to some
interesting things what what is it she's
so hot water yeah a little hot water
after carjackings have increased by 400
percent since 2019 the mayor appeared in
court recently laura in defense of a
young carjacker not the victims
i was in shock she wasn't there for us
she was there
for
the assault and his mother and she felt
like she was supporting the crime well
now mayor latoria cantrell's responding
turns out this young offender was found
guilty of robbing multiple women in
carjackings laura but he had been
through a city internship program the
mayor founded in
so mayor cantrell used her office to
defend the perpetrator
i didn't pick a side that was my way of
supporting this young person that was
required
to participate in a program that the
city of new orleans had created
uh and is funding that's supporting a
young person that has made
decisions
that puts him on a better pathway that's
what i did
no that's really not what you did i mean
if you've got a multiple if you've got a
multiple offender who's beat up and
robbed multiple women and taking their
vehicles they should be thrown in jail
that's the best pathway not
allowing your citizenry to be victimized
twice by paying for this criminal
daycare and uh being robbed at gunpoint
but what did he learn in the internship
that's my question apparently this will
be able to show up and plead your case
in person
uh some interesting skills learned in
the internship courtesy of latoya
raymond um wild wild wild thank you
great to see you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else